so you know I'm I'm taking myself more
to technology writer than a science
writer and what I've reported on over
the years have have been engineering
sciences as much as covering Silicon
Valley which is a business and which is
why I brought Christoph along because I
think there's a real science writer but
I thought I wanted to start with a quote
which you're never supposed to do an
article but I just love this quote so I
thought I begin here which is science
values detailed precision the impersonal
the technical the lasting facts numbers
and being right journalism values
brevity approximation the personal the
colloquial the immediate stories words
and being right now they're going to be
tensions which is which is really true
and it's even more true so what I what I
wanted to do is I wanted to sort of
frame where we are by talking more
initially about sort of we're reporting
and the media's now and Christophe is
going to talk more specifically about
where science journalism is now and
where is going but I think that the
context is the world in which science
journalism is living and it's a time to
really think about the context so this
is what's going on for print journalism
in America right now this is obviously
an extraordinary period by any stretch
of imagination we're in unknown
territory we've gone in a half a decade
from this period where the internet was
clearly undermining the the business
model of mainstream journalism
publishing to this period last year
where there was a concerted political
attack on the traditional watchdog role
of the press last year to this year
where there is a new administration in
Washington that has launched a concerted
attack both on the independent press in
America but also for related reasons and
attack on the credibility and the
financing of the science community as a
whole - and so
so the first time we have the
possibility is extraordinary as it might
have sounded a year ago that actually
doing science writing might soon be seen
as a political act which is which is
extraordinary so how did we get here
so my view on what what's going on in
this transition from print to online
journalism has really changed in the
last six months the blue line of course
is the number of people working for
newspapers the green line is internet
publishing and online writ large and so
it looks like it's kind of promising it
looks like there's this chasm you cross
the chasm and for a long time I would
tell people well look at you know we're
going through this transition old media
is dying but there's all this wonderful
experimentation it's really this great
time in a lot of ways there needs new
new publications popping up and I would
tell this to young journalists
technology writers that you know even
though it's chaotic give it some time
it's going to sort out things will be
okay
and sadly I think I've really changed my
mind the last six months and largely
because of an article I recently read in
Columbia Journalism Review that shows
that it's not true this is what happened
to the hiring of online journalists in
America there was robust growth until
2013 and then it leveled off and it
leveled off at about 10,000 jobs which
is just a fraction of what's gone away
and so that the reality is although
there is a thriving blogosphere which we
can we can I'm sure will talk about that
you know professional journalism the
number of people just absolute people is
declining and it's a it's a it's a big
deal it fits right into this issue that
we're all dealing with I'm not going to
talk so much about fake news although we
could talk for four days about I'm sure
you know Google and Facebook are
struggling to create both human and
algorithmic systems to control the
content on their sites with debatable
luck so far but I wanted to actually
point out another part of the equation
which I think has gotten the less less
attention but is equally in
in intriguing and it's it's perhaps more
difficult to fix because you know the
model of course is advertising its
eyeballs that's what you're monetizing
and I bring it up here because I'm
virtually certain that machine learning
techniques are now being used for
fraudulent generation of of revenue on
the internet it's not so much fake news
it's fake traffic which of course if
you've looked at it all is very much
wound into the fake news problem and the
numbers are are maddeningly hard to
understand but what you have to
understand is they're no good audits
there is no ABC of circulation the way
there is in the print world and so the
consensus seems to be and this is these
are google analytics showing how many of
how much of this traffic does particular
site is coming from bots but the you
know the consensus is it's something
like half of all traffic is now not
human and so we have fake stories being
read by fake humans which is just this
remarkable turn to events in so many
ways you know it's and one great measure
of the emergence of this this phenomenon
if there's now this lively industry of
people basically selling Turing test
systems to publishers so that they can
try to tell whether humans are reading
their their articles or not this is
going to be a losing war i can tell you
if it's an arms race you know the bad
guys are going to win and they may be
winning already you know I really can't
I this is this is a sort of breakdown
I've seen all kinds of numbers that the
bad guys are the 20% numbers I mean
there's a lot of stuff like search
engines that's there that are bots that
are that are not bad but I've seen many
estimates that the actual bad number
traffic is much higher than that perhaps
as much as half of half of all traffic
which of course leads to the sort of
richly ironic point
this is John Wanamaker who was a
invented the last generation of
advertising display advertising and he
said you know a half well a century ago
half the money I spend on advertising is
wasted the trouble is I don't know which
half and if you think about what this
internet revolution was supposed to do
was supposed to give us this in precise
ability to target individuals but the
reality is we basically don't know which
half is right back where we were a
century goat I think it's just
absolutely ironic so I that's I just
wanted to frame the situation facing
science journalism today with that kind
of discussion of the environment
Christophe and I both picked up the same
slide there was the halcyon time which I
guess he's going to point to but I
wanted to just sort of note that for
some reason between 1984 and 1986 45
science sections were created in the
United States and I'd love to go back to
understand why that is the case it's not
immediately clear what was so
interesting I mean Reagan was in office
what why then if you go back to that
revenue slide it was probably because
there was a real bump in newspaper
revenue and a lot of the feature
articles some of them science articles
in the newspaper trader called furniture
and the furniture is sort of what
surrounds the ad and of course when you
get more advertising you need more
furniture and that I think was one of
the things that led to led to the
creation I just sort of wanted to say
where we are now so there are these them
in stat and mosaic are two examples I
just wanted to point out of new
experiments that are interesting but if
you'll note they're both life sciences
oriented or health oriented I'm in a you
know in a cynical way I'd say it's sort
of an example of following the money the
the readership is aging they have more
health problems you present them with
articles about health you can also see
down the corner one of the reasons I
know I was I was in the time side
section for a half a decade it was it
was an experiment from 2010 2015
reporting on reporting on the
engineering sciences within the science
section and as they moved more and more
in sort of Health Director you can see
the tabs but the tabs are environment
space and health and as they moved in
that direction there was less and less
space and so in 2016 I came back to the
technology section just because it was
too hard to get my stuff into the paper
so that's sort of the the high level
sort of framing that I wanted to set
maybe now I can turn the podium over to
to Christophe and then we'll I have some
questions for him and we'll we'll go
from there
[Applause]
dr. Cyril a freelance journalist who
writes regularly for the site and for
the pinch broadcast online media in
Germany it's written a book on how
algorithms are shaping our daily lives a
book on research about music and frame
and lively body at why everybody is
musical and a book on punting logic
among other works it's held the mic
journalism fellowship at MIT and he has
been journalist in residence at the
Calgary Institute for Theoretical
Physics in Santa Barbara
thank you yes I want to talk a little
bit more about the science part in the
science journalism and maybe I have some
more positive things to talk about but I
mean I share the big picture that John
outlined here and I want to go back and
because science journalism is journalism
but it's always been a bit different
from what the other guys in journalism
are doing and if we go back to the
beginnings I call the first era the
cheerleader era when it was the
situation where there was science they
were finding out great things about
nature and and the world and the cosmos
and there was the public who didn't have
a clue about what these people were
doing so they needed an interpreter and
that was a job for science journalists
they had to translate that complicated
language of science into words that
everybody could understand and then the
public
would understand whatever was talking
about so that was the job of the science
journalist and many scientists today
still have the idea that science
journalism job is to you know take their
complicated stuff make it understandable
for the general public and translate it
to them that was maybe in the 1960s
people like Carl Sagan or you can still
have some of these figures today I mean
scientist if you take a magazine like
Scientific American so that the point of
it is led scientists write about their
stuff and you mix it with articles
written by journalists but basically
they're doing the same thing they're
publicizing science if you would say
that to a political writer political
journalist your job is to you know take
what Washington is doing put it in plain
words and put it out to the public they
would probably disagree then came an era
where especially in when people cared
about the environment and there were
problems with science so so the
relationship between the science and the
public was kind of not as harmonious
anymore anymore and there were were
conflicts of interest and scary things
that scientists did they the products of
science polluted the air and everything
and generally started to be watchdogs
and you know look at what was happening
be very critical that was if you if we
take the first generation of writers
that were environmental writers they
were very skeptical everything that that
the biochemical Sciences put out in the
environment and so there was suddenly
there weren't advocates or or
cheerleaders of science anymore there
were critical critics of science and
were very skeptical about it and it was
often a biased kind of journalism and
that that's why I would say the third
era was the one where science writers
really became journalists in the in the
sense that in other beats and politics
or in in the business sections they have
been all along namely people that
take what comes from these fields but
have a critical view on it be competent
enough to judge it and then are only
responsible to their readers to the
public
take influences from science but also
from from industry from politics from
the PR people that are around everywhere
now even in the sciences filter that
stuff and come to a conclusion and tell
that to their readers I found there's an
actual diagram of the of the you know
health communication network it was
called in some in some publication so
it's not only two or three players it's
it's tens of players from from companies
to scientists to shareholders and
whatever and journalists are just one
little cog in this in the system and
they play their role there and the
traditional situation was that we had
this this wall that we had between all
these people and the public and we used
to be the doorkeepers we you know
decided what gets through to the public
after our deliberations and research and
in the best of all worlds it was good
research and it was sorrow and it was
actually something that that was good
for people and then and then came the
Internet right and oh this is John slide
about that it was actually in science
this thing about the increasing number
of science sections and yeah between 80
84 and 86 47 daily newspapers began
weekly science sections and then they
had ones that had only one page that was
counted though it was a ton of stuff
there was a time when I started becoming
a science journalist there were programs
trying to bring scientists into
journalism because they didn't have
enough people to fill all these new
pages not only in the US also in other
countries like the Fellowship's were
founded like night fellowship at MIT so
big time and then came the internet and
at first it was great it was well it
burned down that wall but first
first we had that vault still so I
remember when I had in access as a
journalist and the public didn't have
internet yet that was a minority it was
so great that we could find stuff now
online which we had to make a ton of
phone calls or send faxes out to to
institution I remember when I Duke was
doing a article on NASA in the early 90s
I was sitting in Germany at the
freelance writer just with my phone and
fax machine and I had to get this was a
report on the Challenger disaster it was
a printed brochure that was it wasn't
like secret material that had to find
out but just to get this mailed from
NASA to Germany I was one of the few
people who had this in in my hand and I
could base the story on it with
additional interviews but it was just
the access to information was so hard
for for ordinary people that that we had
a this privilege of getting this and
then when we had access and the others
didn't it was even better for us to get
a lot more easier to find especially in
the scientists because the science
science people were the first ones on
the net right so it was very easy for us
to get information and then give it to
the public but then this wall burned
down but because everybody was on the
internet now and so suddenly these
people could talk directly to the public
so we were we were somewhere in the
middle there but these arrows went past
us suddenly could everybody could go in
the internet and find information and
when we published online articles they
started commenting and if we if we had
an error or mistake they were pointing
it out immediately before you could get
away with the little stuff right now you
can't if the number is wrong or a fact
as long as they come at you immediately
and the public can talk back with
comments and whatever so we are suddenly
in the middle of this network of people
who talk to each other and the question
is and that may be something which we
can get into in the discussion is what's
our job there what's special I mean we
can write nicely is that necessary do
you need that if you want information or
what's our what what what do we bring
into that
mixture that makes it worth paying as
money for it right when you can get
everything for free and so we have a new
continuum of publication on the one hand
is the pure science scientific
publications in the lingo from
scientists for scientists then you have
classical journalism on the other side
but there's a lot in between there is
scientists that write blogs there are
professional bloggers and so you can
have all kinds of levels of specificity
or be more closer or further away from
the actual science in science writing
and for the reader if I see myself as
the reader it's a great thing if I can
read like something like quantum
magazine that is that is financed by the
Science Foundation it's a great
publication because I as someone who is
a mathematician myself so I can read a
little bit of the lingo but not the
original publication I find a new level
of writing of good creative writing
that I wouldn't get in a general
interest newspaper because they would
say that's to complicate can we can have
that here so we have this new spectrum
which is great
of course the open question is who of
these people can make money on what
they're doing and what is a sustainable
business model for these publications in
some cases like quanta it's a foundation
that says ok you take the money and do
something good with it I don't know if
that's a you can generalize that model
or if you still have have to have
publications based on advertising or
even readers paying for it and I think
no one has a solution at the moment and
that's what we're all looking for and
John gave you the numbers it's a big
problem and with that problem
we're stuffy discussion II maybe we
could to this so why don't we start I
think this is wonderful in one sense
that the scientists can directly reach
the reader there's in the cut us out
they cut out the middleman but is it is
it
all positive I mean what happens so I
began to think about conflict of
interest if the if the scientist has
unfettered access to the to the to the
readership over the audience yeah does
that does that completely serve the
reader well the first question I would I
would reply with or the first answer I
would give you is have science
journalism ever been really critical
journalism in the way that you know you
have to be in order to criticize
something you have to be competent and
if you have if you're a science even if
it's big institutions like New York
Times or our paper we had like five or
six science writers for all of science
and you can't be an expert in everything
so you it's always a question whether
you can report critically on what
science is doing if you don't understand
the basics of it order so you always
need someone in that country and it's in
this foreign country called science as
your guards that you can rely on that
gives you stories and information use
and I would argue that's where
traditional journalistic methods come
into play I mean the stories that I've
written that have sort of looked at bad
acting and science have all come from
sources within the scientific community
itself people who see things and you
sort of bring you into that community
and that that that seems to be something
I mean to extent the blogosphere could
do that the blogosphere is doing that I
don't know if they're doing it any
better of a job than we did it that we
did over time and please you know if
let's let's open this up to whatever
degree
we'd like to if there are questions um
yeah
here's what role you think journalists
are invited that
Tooting public opinion what kind of
responsibility we had for the fact that
the thank you want to take another pass
with so that's a very difficult question
to I mean for just personally of someone
who sort of worked inside the cathedral
if you will for a long time I mean I you
know I'm a little bit different than the
most traditional journalists because I
actually you know began my career if you
will as an activist and was politically
active for many years and then I at
certain point I decided that there was a
value in journalism as as separate from
activism that there was a role in
society for this party that I thought it
was a fair witness and that I mean I was
I was almost like a religious thing on
my part I changed what I did and I
thought okay this is this is this is
part of democracy this is this is this
role that the Constitution is preside
provided and I tried to take that
position and now when you sort of see us
I mean just I mean I there's not a day
that goes by where my social media
stream is not full of people who believe
that the Washington Post in the New York
Times lie that's a belief and there's
absolutely nothing I can do I mean I'm
just sort of feel hopeless I you know to
engage them you know why do you believe
this well it's a I don't know that I can
dissuade them from their belief it's
this new era that we're in which may be
very much like I mean so maybe the the
anomaly is actually to have this kind of
press that tried to be a fair witness I
mean in Europe at least my perception of
Europe is that traditionally political
parties have had allied papers and press
has been adversarial and am I am i right
nothing up every every paper is aligned
with the party right yeah not true not
that way but yeah they all have but like
here right I mean the New York Times is
not objective somewhere in the political
spectrum well it's sort of funny so it
depends on where you stand because I
funny I mean I I mean I see all these
people you know attacking
the New York Times for being such a
liberal publication is my guy you know
it's funny I'm being inside it's night I
say to myself unnie it seems so
right-wing to me so you know it really
does depend on where you stand so that's
it's a sort but I think you have to
answer the question differently for
different branches of science if you're
reporting on like stem cell research or
something that has a lot of implications
for the public and for the lives of
people you have to follow it you have to
be very skeptical you have to really
bring in people's interest into the game
if you report on mathematics which I do
from time to time it's really you you
don't you don't follow the science
closely and report on everything that's
happening you pick you pick stuff out of
it maybe Erika can tell us about it you
try to pick stories that you can that
you can relate to it to a general
audience and it's not the the most
important resource it's happening but
it's sorry that our yeah that you can
explain the question so in methods often
hard to explain even the question not
let alone the answer to a certain
problem right so that's certainly not
critical reporting in the sense of you
know different secrets that can conflict
with each other so one of the things I
have trouble understanding is someone
who tries to follow you know feels
computing for example as a journalist
and as a reader the decline of you know
if there are fewer journalists to what
extent has that slack been picked up by
the blogosphere if you will and it's
it's hard it's just hard for me to tell
him in some sense it seems like a really
rich and lively time there's something
on everything and yet it's it's not
systematic and so I wonder was it ever
well there were points at which you had
a large number of professional
journalists who had who had beats and
there was a structure for example in in
30 years ago in Silicon Valley there was
there were there were weekly
publications there were daily
publications and
were trade publications that were weekly
and there was a very clear structure and
you could you know you knew that there
was someone who was an expert at a
certain level who was falling every
detail in that field I saw a research
paper that looked at the field of
nanotechnology and found that there were
at 2011 in the u.s. 429 journalists who
had written stories about nano tech
technological subjects but then when you
actually sort of looked at how many of
them had written they set the bar at 25
which seemed to be a little bit high to
us but that number 25 stories by a
single byline in a single year that
number fell to 7 reporters so it was it
just seemed like there that the kind of
beat reporting and maybe you're right
maybe maybe if you're not doing as a
beat we're in touch with the people who
are the practitioners in the field then
something's lost it seems to be and you
know I don't know to which you know I
know there's some bloggers who take this
on as profession of professionals and
you know maybe in a sense the
independent journalist is the model of
life or maybe you're actually the future
you're you're sort of I mean you have a
both of us actually now have sort of an
independent journalist catcher maybe the
future is the journalist is a brand and
you follow the individual as opposed to
following the institution I don't see
the I don't see the revenue stream yeah
it's a problem maybe you know there's so
for the science who is your readership
who is consuming what you're writing
science right and I don't mean the first
optic step I've got it already Felicity
sighs but the other stuff is that are
not politicized we actually are building
the a really consumption and module who
are the people why are they reading
through fine
so I I had a mental model in my mind
when I was a science journal at the New
York Times that I was sort of writing
for the person who also wrote read
Scientific American so there was a
college educated and formed an
interested person who was not an expert
in the field but wanted to know what was
going on but that was you know that was
before this that was when the wall was
there and I it was a model in my head I
didn't really know he always had the
wife of a dentist in a small town in
Germany no well that there always was a
spectrum right of more more or less
general audience publications but if you
take a general audience publication like
deep sight is I don't know most of you
won't know it it's a weekly paper in
Germany and on the contrary to what John
showed we I would say we because I left
two years ago they have a circulation
that's actually rising it's 500,000
weeks in print that's or it's
stabilizing there they're scared
completely scared about the future
because the ads are going down but it's
a different story the circulation
basically is is kept at a level and for
that publication it was always the great
advantage of a newspaper is that it's a
limited space so you have a give you a
reader package every week what you think
is important or interesting or funny or
entertaining this week and you offer
that package to them and they're happy
with it and then they stay your
customers most of them complain it's too
much already but of course in this
internet world it's it's bottomless and
every online publication is bottomless
the New York Times online you know
they're scared you know that of people
who scroll and ever reach the bottom at
you want reach the bottom and yeah
that's a and that's a difference and if
you are bottomless you can of course go
into into arbitrary detail and be very
specific whereas if you have this this
weekly package that's limited in space
and you have to make editorial decisions
and decide what you what you're saying
is
and the other thing was we didn't have
click rates for single articles in the
past and still don't evidence in printer
land so no one if I would write a little
math piece people are saying okay no
one's reading that anyway but but we're
putting it in there we can't control for
it we can only can you know have the
success of the whole package in the end
now they've found techniques to do that
in print every couple of months and
online every story is rated immediately
by the people who read it and then you
see how that priorities change and
suddenly the science might might go to
the bottom of the page the other thing
that's going on is there's tremendous
convergence of media that's really
shaking things up in really interesting
ways you know I lived and died as a
print reporter I couldn't figure out how
to create a graph or actually take a
video X I once got it I once got a ride
on a submarine in Monterey Bay and which
was great it was really fun but I had a
camera and there was an algae bloom and
so you couldn't see out the window of
the submarine and I filed this video and
somebody posted it was the worst video
they'd ever seen on online I knew that I
wasn't going to be a more than a print
reporter but but the Times has done two
experiments that I think are really
illustrative about five years ago we did
something called snowfall which actually
which was about an avalanche in
Washington in which we tried to sort of
converge the three you know print
animated graphics and video and sound
and and sort of create this new media in
less than artificial way and it was
beautiful it took the times probably
twenty or thirty people in six months to
produce one story so it was very
difficult I haven't seen progress and
tools come very quickly more recently a
more interesting experiment which I just
looked at it was just amazing to me
um a young social media editor at The
New York Times was walking down the
street in New York and she looked down
on the street and she saw a slide of
photographic slide and she picked it up
and it was kind of interesting it was
looking at you and then she saw there
was a trail of them and the times at
this point had this experiment going we
still have this experiment going with
Facebook with Facebook live and so she
turned on her her camera and she began
sort of telling the story tell
wearing this what she was finding on
Facebook live and she took these slides
and they led to a garbage can where
there was a bag of slides and she began
to look through them and so they were
really well done slides and she sort of
became a detective and discovered that
they were the slide collection of a now
dead
science writer for Newsweek who had been
dead for four years and it turned out
that her her former boyfriend had kept
the slides in his apartment for four
years and then sort of had this some
sort of emotional crisis and threw them
out and I mean if you if you go to the
time to look at it it was it was an
example to me of a really good job it
what looks like a new media and sense
it's an old mia because if any of you
remember Max Headroom which was this
British science fiction film in the
1980s where the investigative reporter
carried a camera based Sony betacam
around on his shoulder and and talked to
an AI at the same time it was a
wonderful show but this was sort of a
step in that direction and so I got a
glimpse of this new media of this sort
of sort of you know seamless and sort of
wonderful blurring of the lines of these
separate technologies but it's really
hard you also have to have a good story
she had a really nice story um so this
is well lay off I have question dad's
familial don't feeling that insulator
and asked a question about like new new
mediums I feel like there's been you
know the times that I think it's a
publication there's a lot of really cool
kind of interactive things that actually
do take advantage of the web
in unique attributes over printers TV or
whatever but I feel like at least from
my point of view like the kind of we've
barely brush the surfaces like what what
is conceivable and like cities a lot of
stories are told and as this kind of you
know like the way traditional stories
hold like a linear like narrative kind
of article thing in all kids to me where
it doesn't really make sense to do it at
all for example like if you're covering
like a political speech or something
there will be a sort of a linear sort of
summary or cert or something of it have
you seen like like I guess when ask me
is like why do you think there hasn't
been so I what I've seen and I wish I
could this is like a couple of years ago
I was spending a lot of time is there
there are experiments with new tools for
storytelling
they've all been and there's some and
I'm blanking on names there are some
really beautiful ones out there that are
you know it's just this all of a sudden
they're you know there are million
vectors you can go in any direction and
so there's the tools are beginning to be
played with I don't say I don't think
they've emerged yet in any useful way
for people like me that and also you
know there's there's a there's different
kinds of activities there's this notion
of storytelling where you don't have a
deadline you just sort of work on the
story until you until you get I for most
of my career lived in a world where you
work to a deadline and there it's
amazing how little the tools have
changed for people who you know who are
in a competitive situation and have to
you know do it as quickly as possible
they're not you know since the invention
of the word processor we've come very we
haven't come very far it seems to me do
you seem well that's what what I think
is is new is data journalism data-driven
stories that can combine with
infographics and you you can do amazing
stuff with that like I added a whole
page indeed side for the last five years
that was just a graphic page it was
static scores was on paper but just
telling stories and graphics not just
have some some
like like Excel diagrams but having
illustration and and data together and
of course online you can do a lot more
with this because it can move it can be
interactive and but it's a lot of work
for example and it's expensive it's
still not so automated these tools that
you can just you know throw a bunch of
data in and then the great story comes
out so all these new forms don't talk
about this long form online stuff it's
all labor intensive still and only only
big big companies can can do that and it
yeah you have to invest in people and
doing that and and if you look at the
figure that you showed most online
publications I remember not doing
something that would Schwieger online
some some interactive stuff if I tell
you what they pay me for that you'll be
laughing at me so it's it's still a lot
of work that you put into that and to
pay people to work on one story for
several weeks multiply a weekly salary
by the time and that's not everybody can
pay that so the question was that does
that separate small public need to be
there and it more like Internet has
brought a common pound between politics
and that was like the old world that
from the view of a journalist there was
a public on one side that was the the
people you are facing and it that who's
advocate you are and then there's the
big nasty dirty world behind you that to
try to sort the information from and I
think that's over that's that was the
the idea of my slides that this time is
past that you're just sitting there as a
doorkeeper to information to the public
it's it's all going rushing past you and
you have to find your special role in
that and and one of the roles is well
first of all you can
invest if you're a paid professional
journalist you can invest more time into
getting to the bottom of things and if
you're a good writer you can tell
stories in a way that that the the pure
facts that might come from science or
from somewhere else you know I'll do so
you good storytelling is more more than
ever a good good quality that a
journalist listening I'm trying to
continue the media conversation a little
longer and I'm all for the really great
data graphics that York Times and
Bloomberg and so on have been innovating
on in fact I teach that but my question
is more the other direction as not the
New York Times but the other journalists
need to be moving a lot more tortuous
straight shot video and just generally
communications needs to be video and not
writing and so I wondering what you
think the future of the written word is
in general the expired terrorism or
general tournament is it a very limited
feature even for those who prefer to be
I've watched the the move to video I'm
still not sure as all this comes
slamming together this is where I'd get
really frustrated I thought it would
sort itself out over a decade now I
think that maybe it's just going to be
chaotic for the foreseeable future The
Times is experimented for example with
video over and over and again and I've
watched as higher entire teams of video
geographers and then fire them all and
we've done that two or three times as
we've tried to find our way and then
there are these startups like vice and
and others that are doing video or in a
journalist in some of its it's just
great but I'm not sure if it's if it's
being funded by you know venture capital
investment or whether there's actually a
real business there I sort of want to
wait and see that we're seeing the rise
of a new media here or whether it's an
artifact of Silicon Valley venture
capital and we'll be washed away I don't
think it's clear yet
and all these other sites and they seem
to have very little written text the New
York Times is a holdout I would say like
that's quite interesting
I can tell you from decide online people
love to read long stories they get more
clicks than the short stories but for
example we haven't talked about facebook
at all people listen less people go to
the you know to the home page of a
newspaper and look what's on the menu
but they get their get their feeds from
Facebook and from stories that are
linked there and of course on Facebook
video works better than just text and
they don't have audio really but so you
have these one minute in a in a one
minute video that's some of the most
clicked items on Facebook so this
Facebook algorithm decides more and more
about what people get to get offered at
all and then also what they click and
what they what they read so and and I
don't know if all I think I think no
publisher really has an answer to how to
deal with that right the New York Times
just stopped collaborating with with
Facebook on these two direct stories
that you publish on Facebook and so
they're all were all victims or subjects
of these of these algorithms that they
put in place
I guess so like from my point of view
pure math and I see what I look up to
your science do a much poor job it's a
theoretical physics and popularizing
themselves and I guess I've thought a
bit about it being a good thing
to popularize out there yes but I've
also play devil's advocate advocate for
myself and I want to just ask you about
it
are there downsides to popularize in
there you can achieve manator even
especially if it's I guess there's two
things one might be the population sees
it in kind of an oversimplified way like
with quantum mechanics exactly so on the
second side the scientists themselves
could it kind of has it in other fields
you having some kind of inflation to be
like impressive to the pocket to the
population or if some scientist move
over on this spectrum yeah if this
drives some source inflation where you
kind of drive the field towards just
being the hot topic well well it's an
old story that scientists who go out
into the public are a snob done by their
by their peers I don't think that
there's some of these superstars here
there were more name names but where you
think do they do science anymore or
either on an only on TV and they might
get some yeah bad raps but as opposed
enough not to your question physics has
the advantage that it's still talking
about the real world so even if it's
quantum mechanics that you can put it in
you know and then there was this soup of
particles and a big bang whatever it
still related to the world that people
know so it's it's harder with pure math
or theoretical computer science but can
there be over popularization I think
what's bad is when when they like rush
out stuff that they had
like like for example with exoplanet
research right always about the new
second earth that they found although
they aren't Earth's and there are a lot
of other conditions and they don't know
anything about these plants because you
can't look at them you have to have a
very indirect methods of talking about
what's happening on them and there's
always an artist's impression of how it
might look Larry just waiting to see the
aliens crawling on the surface and that
might be and there and they're rushing
these stories out to the public very
quickly as soon as they have the results
them there might be a danger in playing
overplaying that but otherwise popular
popularizing science is a great thing
and I can't get enough of that yeah so
you know oftentimes it also it's really
often not by the journalist but by
what's going on either in science and
technology I mean it's interesting to
note if any of you remember the movie
The Graduate which is now 50 years old
this year it's a half a century old
it was a UC Berkeley Graduate he went to
UC and that was that wonderful scene in
which the family member walks up to him
and said I have one word for you word is
plastics and we all know if he'd walked
up to him now that would have been two
words machine learning and it's just I
mean it's just stunning the the the way
machine learning is taken over the
conversation and I mean I know that's
more applied than it is theoretical but
it really dominates the the journalistic
landscape now so you know I don't think
we have a corner of doing well in
Silicon Valley yeah a Silicon Valley
corner of the I'm continually surprised
by I had to pay a piece in The Times
yesterday on flying cars and I was in
you know almost every quote in the
article except on people in the in the
in the from the company was negative I
was not trying to hype this up it was
something that Larry Page was doing
there were 800 comments I don't think
I've ever written an article the New
York Times has gotten as many comments
and so there's I don't know what is the
Jetsons that we all grew up with or that
people in my generation why was there so
much interest in something like that I
I'm mystified because people hate
traffic yeah maybe that's it
although there's always second-order
effects I mean this is the thing that
just drives me crazy about the the you
know the autonomous vehicle argument for
for for sparing us from traffic is it's
just a dream I'm already in San
Francisco you can see but even before we
get to autonomous cars and since there
are no limits on uber or lyft vehicles
we have this huge congestion problem
they'll have I will have more because
people won't park their cars anymore
they'll guard a deserted circle yeah and
everybody will still it'll be easier to
travel and everybody will want to go
someplace at the same time which is a
recipe for disaster as far as I can so
but what we were talking about it I
wouldn't call it over popularization but
over selling of stuff of science and
that's a trend every science department
has a has a PR department now and that's
the job for four critical Jo them to you
know separate the wheat from the chaff
or whatever well so the weekly chart
innocence I might turn things around and
ask this community something because one
of the things that's happened for me as
a technology writer who's covered the
field of computer science as you flip
the model and gone to publish before you
peer-review it's made things extremely
confusing and maybe it's making better
science I'm not sure but from the point
of view of a journalist is trying to
understand what's the value in reporting
on it becomes extremely difficult when
everything is archived and I haven't
sorted that out yet I mean I would love
to hear how you know is it you you go
back I fall back on the the things I've
always thought back and I have trusted
experts and I ask them but my network is
a you know it's a bias network by
definition and so I don't really know
how to to solve that problem to the
degree it's a problem the answer Pro is
that the peer reviewed research wasn't
any better right yeah there's a lot of I
mean yeah we always used to quote it was
in the scientific journal named blah
blah and now we know how much how much
[ __ ] I think it's they're really
very scientific yeah that's possible and
circle
this is very interesting and I think you
know it's clear that this is a huge
problem for science journalists that's
changed the land of opportunities from
the readers perspective it's not as
clear that it's the problem I think
there's a lot of very high quality
content that's available and maybe it's
an issue of curating your own penis how
you select and even judge what the
sources are and then different people
with different backgrounds will have
different abilities to discriminate and
and so maybe societally this problem
that you're experiencing in science
journalism
it seems very parallel to the problem
with respect to other other parts of
print journalism that there's been this
kind of disintegration of norms around
what actual news is there's no consensus
on there's a broad consensus
unfortunately in nationally about what
actually constitutes real news and I'm
just wondering even for this a little
bit in a broader context about you know
what the real consequences are for us as
citizens as readers well science is
different from the rest of the world in
the way that it is a method and it has
institutions and as bad as it might I
just said that there's a lot of false
some stuff in journals but still it's
it's been peer-reviewed right what do we
want peer review so it has some kind of
control mechanism this it might be
flawed and and the overhaul and but
there there is you can always go back to
a source and then there's authorities
and in news it's the general news it's
you know anybody's guess right well
there's a lot that's lost I mean you
know I admit that there are good
bloggers who I use as guides through
fields and they've turbine editorial
function but there's another function of
an editor diary that it's lost in the
blogosphere and that is as we're all
atomized one of the best things about
working at The New York Times as I work
collaboratively and you only saw my
byline but the product was the result
of a group of people and I actually
think that improves the quality of the
product so when you atomized everything
everybody's in there in their pajamas
you know that's wonderfully liberating
but it might not make for a better
product it's some kind of peer review to
write and fact-checking I mean hardly
anybody has fact checkers anymore but if
you have a real good fact checker that's
sitting and asking you you know where
did you get that piece of it right
because everybody who writes you know
even if you if you don't want to write
anything wrong you love the stuff that
you collect that you don't want to throw
it out and then you might not check it
thoroughly now and then there's these
guys that but they're not around anymore
right most of its maybe at the New
Yorker you kinda know at the New York
Times to the time that Times has had
copiers we're cutting back copy editors
I think sadly but The Times has never
accepted the magazine section they
detect a Dan oops women Erica sorry I'm
asking questions though about
popularization is the role of journals
with an ecosystem like polycon and
science so I think Haller wanted my
first question about what the role of
journalism and the deterioration of
public opinion so I think nutrition
science and health is an area where
there's already something of a selection
bias in terms of what gets into
high-profile journals and add on top of
that the journalistic tendency to go for
things they're surprising you get this
very biased election which is probably
more often than not baking things that
are false and then to the public who's
trying to want to you know eat more junk
food but still lose weight and then
negative energy would stop that [ __ ]
basically and then in the night
experience is another example I think of
something like vertical example of
houses public as men explains like for
example climate change something like
that where the constant is so massive
and the whole idea that consensus is
relevant right is saying 10 percent in
sciences for concern and what the stake
is says collapse of civilization and
that might warrant hedging but somehow
we somehow the idea that consensus is
important it kind of still it's repeated
and if that important is unequivocal so
I mean I define as it gradually cars
journal is not incredibly important role
when there's like physical elements
perverting it and then both alike
ignoring both of the role of certain
eastern edges so journalism has to be
where mystical consequences of how it
supports information there could a Jew a
question mention that quantity
what I do it's great yeah if you have a
rich foundation all the problems you
can't let anything go yeah that matter
was it matter was it mosaic is supported
by the Wellcome Trust so it's another
example of something like quantum we
need more rich people in solution may be
unfair to sort of put the burden on
chocolates and things like given
original kind of science which you have
this population values which are more
you know it's time to publish something
in the door know and you know it's
basically some sort of non-existent
saying how can you know Jonathas read
that sort of well I hiding a matter
tight it's purely about business thing
on have lots of articles about this you
might but I mean I guess maybe I wonder
like what kind of obligation you have
you on business
well there are publications that have to
determine that something is wrong you
know we pop you if you have a kind of an
expert relevant it was okay to answered
vomit one is there's a whole genre of
journalism like magazines women's
magazines you have to churn out a new
diet every couple of months right so
they have to find something
revolutionary in it of course it's not
but I wouldn't that's not science
writing and the thing about and then we
would have to talk about science itself
as you look at magazines like like
science and nature which are not
journalistic products in the first place
but scientific drones they have a
selection bias for for things that sound
very revolutionary and new and if you
talk to a statistician you will say fit
one one experiment one publication and
it's a very extraordinary result it's
very likely that it's that it's false
right that if so and then of course
journalists come and pick that out and
have the apple of science and nature on
it because we pick those the you know
the
Man Bites Dog stories over the dog bites
man
yeah at response to your second part I
think was a super interesting I think
like you know it's not common in our
culture at all to think using like some
understanding probability in like a
expert value and reasoning in this way
and I don't think it's just fair either
even though I think it's a super
interesting point to put the burden on
journals like I think that's probably
going for the education system to like
teach people like oh you should you
should like go to expect that okay
what's up but um also like I wanted to
ask a question about Adams like you you
painted this picture we're like okay
yeah ad revenues are declining and also
we don't understand or we think that
most are let's say half of all good
eyeballs or whatever are our thoughts so
I guess that means that like that does
that mean that advertisers are our
advertisers less because they think that
they're spending their money on box or
well I've started to I mean you know
Facebook was embarrassed publicly about
two or three months ago when they had to
admit that they they were counting their
videos all wrong and the advertisers
were being ripped off and there been a
set of things that have suggested that
the advertisers should change their
behavior actually should wake up and
there is some evidence I think that
they've started to but by and large you
know they're the the advertisers have
been in this new system the sucker is
being played and we're starting to see
the advertiser to change behavior but up
until now they have been funding this
new ecosystem that's been exploited by
fake news been part of they have been
the heart of the problem actually
and Google is winning right yeah to get
piece of all the cake yeah so with
increasing diversification
more and more fears are coming up the
only thing that it's inevitable that has
more than residue of talent and skill on
people who are introducing those
concepts humanity now we talk about the
scientists of the journalist line
between the scientists and as probably
you have a crowdsource suggestion the
people and also has more and more people
to modeling you have a larger and more
stable markets and more and more players
will come in and probably focusing and
go for recap I feedback decreases all
these changes the government's opinions
on which science one man do you think
there's a way I was in your camp until I
until I discovered that there were you
know there was a very relatively small
group of people in this new world who
were being paid to work as journalists
so I would have if that was right if
there's going to be this you know sort
of lively new ecosystem you think it
would be bubbling up opportunities for a
new class of journalists and I'm hoping
that you're right and that's what will
emerge it's just I was very disheartened
to see where we are right now and maybe
you know maybe it's maybe it's early and
but it seems like this technology is
reinventing itself regularly I mean you
know we've gone from desktop to this
handheld thing just in the last five
years now everybody's reading their news
and in this format I don't think this is
the end of the road I'm willing to bet
you that there's some new format and
everything trans is transformed once
more in the next five years whether it's
augmented reality or what it is this is
not some of the end of the line and you
know since the medium is the message
that every new medium creates a new
structure and I think it's going to just
continue to today yeah we kind of
mislabeled is opening because we were
talking about the future and we we have
a hard time talking about the present
right we don't quite understand the
present yet and that's it it's the
galloping exactly a question or whatever
it occurs to me I have two teenage
2:15 and all they do and what not all of
it a lot of what they do online is what
YouTube videos and these guys you know
and they know they actually know a lot
of that these guys have millions of
viewers and they're making a lot of
money off of this that's not included in
what you're talking about
well I mean is it journalism versus
entertainment or can you direction you
can you divide I see a little bit of
both yeah about getting eyeballs that's
very good well that's right they did you
see this no and in fact you could that
could be the point it from which this
new ecosystem is emerging maybe it's
already there I don't go to youtube now
for my science journalism by and large
although I'm starting to see things but
I and I know that the people you're
talking about are making billions of
dollars they're usually comics I mean at
least in YouTube now and I mean they're
great fun to watch but you know that Dan
Rather hasn't moved over there
successfully I mean I don't see maybe
right I just don't see it yet and if
you're talking about people who make
money on YouTube it's a very thin layer
of cream on top of the yes that's
children look at your numbers in like
maybe there's more of those youtubers
than it's possible it's possible but I
mean are any of you have [ __ ] I mean
your 13 year old kids are any of you
have [ __ ] ooh ated to getting your news
from YouTube yeah I understand I
understand okay so you know wait a
decade
yeah well I mean so III was part of this
phenomenon that really began in terms of
covering consumer technologies I mean
that was sort of what paid the freight
and so my career started largely because
all of a sudden there was this industry
called the personal computer industry
and it had publications and there was an
astute who's sucking sound as they
needed journalists and you know just
because of my own interest dot I've
always felt that there should be a role
for technology reporting that doesn't
sit in the business section it's always
been a trouble you can never figure out
where to put technology writers I mean
when I first came to the New York Times
it was my mind to my mind it was a
wonderful pier because there was a
weekly box for reporting that I called
explanatory technology writing which was
not science writing but it sort of it
was similar and sometimes it did shape
directly into science writing and you
know that that went away and it you know
the for a while The Times had a consumer
technology section like many papers that
came and went very quickly we went with
the combo but it all vanished but you
know there I mean I you know there
engineering sciences I felt my role was
to report on the you know the advances
in that in those fields and their impact
on society which is a little bit
different than being in the business
section of it I mean although that's
where it would sit
on the repin has been a terrific
dialogue and I'm sure we could go on for
long silence right here I think it might
be good to take just one or two more
questions and then we will think the
speakers about you were saying tech and
business section you know I think you
were trying to say they should be more
separate or all right well I often you
know in an ideal world I think that
there would be a sort of a place for
writing about the impact of technology
on society and there are there are
publications to focus on a story by John
Kerry guru about the paranhos math Wow
yeah well that's yeah and that you could
not you you could argue that should be
in the business section I mean I was
well I was in a war the Wall Street
Journal it's similar with with media
topics like the New York Times has you
know when you have sorry about Fox News
and their allegations it's in the
business section although they doesn't
talk about dollars yeah none at all but
just about sexual harassment the other
and so you sits in the business X yeah I
mean the notion of sections in
newspapers is rather new just
historically it's on its own right
okay one last question
well few have been operating in
countries that have a relatively free
press if you were just describing the
state of Science and Technology
journalism in countries that are less
gender democratic and less free would
you see a very different situation well
my experience the only place I have
experiences in China where I've spent
some time and they in terms of writing
about technology in science they have
very lively of and I can't read their
language but just in talking to their
journalists it's pretty clear that there
is a lively journalistic community there
even though they don't I mean you know
and going to China now I just felt so
much like my god I've arrived in Silicon
Valley it feels exactly like Silicon
Valley and some some ways and then all
of a sudden if you spend sometimes
people you realize oh yeah in every way
except they don't have this thing called
democracy you know culturally it's very
similar what's up without this sort of
little quirk about democracy so and I
can tell you that for example in Eastern
Europe and times of communism they had a
lot of reporting on technology of course
not in any critical way about about
their nuclear power plants or things
like that but that was some part that
was that they that they you know held up
and now in other countries I don't know
the world meeting of science journalists
will be intent oh yes Arabic October so
in October here you can maybe peek peek
in or maybe I'll hear about great will
have to wear this in the future and it's
like thank you
you